congrats on the movie
thank you i'm definitely curious what
were you
at all nervous about making the sequel
after the success of the first film
because it was so good or were you sort
of like
john has this well
i mean at first just like you said i
thought
well everything was so perfect in the
first one so
do you want to ruin that do you want to
take a chance on ruining that to do the
to do a second one but john had an idea
he called us
on facetime and he said what if and he
rolled out the story and i said oh my
god john you're brilliant yes we have to
do this
and after that we just felt so confident
in the building of this world and
um it and you know i had the confidence
and everything was right all the
ingredients were right you if
all those things are in place you can
make it as you see we did it
when i spoke to john and emily earlier
today
i brought up a quiet place three because
uh
when the movie ended the sequel i
immediately wanted more
um and john has said that he has ideas
for the third
so are you uh already asking him about
doing another one
well really i have no idea if there's a
third
but i i would love to know what john has
in mind
and uh see if we could make the story
work again
yeah who knows yeah he made it seem like
him and emily
came up with a trilogy well let's hope
so
he didn't tell me that but who knows
i think he's in a good mood today
because everyone is loving the movie
i love the movie i just saw it last
night for the first time
and i was just overtaken oh my god i
mean i still have like a head anxiety
headache from
you know like so much tension watching
the movie uh what was the first
thing that you filmed and what was the
last thing that you filmed
without spoilers i don't know how to
answer that but i don't know how to do
this
i think the first
was i think it was with killian the
first scene was with
killian and the last scene was um solo
okay i accept um when you
got the script for the sequel what were
you
really excited to film and what were you
maybe a little nervous to film
uh we john laid out the story through
facetime again and when he was
presenting the story
uh i was all in when i read the script
um i saw how action heavy it was
i was surprised but i was still really
in it i wanted to
i would do anything to support john and
i actually had a lot of confidence in
this story
uh how do you think that you've because
the first movie it's like
the first big thing how do you think you
changed maybe as an actor
getting ready for the second one or
making the second one compared to the
first film
um i there are many similarities
partly because i'm working with the same
cast in this a similar story
but um
but of course when a quiet place the
incidents happen that of course changed
the trajectory of the story in this one
and how she deals with it and how and
this film is so much more physically
demanding
but you know like i said we did it